Jack you you got material on this show
the last time did you yeah it's because
you had uh sure on he was the other
guests who might I say it's not a patch
on these two lovely ladies my recent
tour bus driver had uh sure before me
and he said he was really the he was in
the we shouldn't you'll notice I'm not
saying anything
he hasn't got any good talking stories
he was in the green room and I my
parents were then I brought them along
to the show and I thought it'd be a nice
idea for me to introduce my dad to usher
internationally acclaimed rap superstar
so a hip-hop and soul R&B artist my
father
the my dad asked us for directions to
his seat because he thought uh sure was
an usher
[Applause]
I went for a win with Jennifer Aniston
and it wouldn't let me in the toilet and
I met a year before with John Mayer and
then she's like no it's fine you can
come and you can when we sat down and I
could hear it how are you honey and I
just called her Rachel
[Applause]
it's come out
[Music]
you